what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so with regards to the MCU videos
that we've done so far
normally Thursday's are our x-men days
but the x-men series is gonna it's a
long-running series of videos it'll take
us a long time like we'll be pretty
close to the end of 2018 if not past
2018 by the time we finish it all right
now we're kind of hitting the highlights
or probably go back and hit like the
smaller stories in between but because
of the fact that is such a long-running
series and Sundays is the day when we do
long-running series for Green Lantern we
might just slap the two together and
just do Green Lantern and x-men on the
same day and just double up on Sundays
but that would leave Thursday's open to
us I'm not sure yet I might just leave
x-men on Thursdays and then just put
this alongside it as well at the end it
all comes out to be the kind of the same
thing but with regards to the MCU films
that we've done so far the phases that
we've done so far
remember x-men phase 1 Fantastic Four
phase 1 x-men face - that's not really
designed to be an entire face just kind
of the best way I could think of to
essentially say these are the x-men
movies I would do I mean in truth if
that was a singular face there's one
point where we have like eight x-men
movies which means we would have
something like 16 or 17 years of nothing
but x-men films and that would drive
people insane like that would drive
people up the wall so we're not gonna
keep it that way just because you know
honestly I probably wouldn't even watch
that to be to be quite frank I'd get
burned out and I'd want to go do
something else I don't want to see
something else going on so because that
we'd have to kind of arrange those
movies in a way where it makes sense as
part of the larger MCU and it would go
through with like numerical numbers I
mean right now you know infinity war and
Avengers 4 will in phase 3 which means
we go into phase 4 5 6 7 all the way up
to like this right now which would be
phase 8 now with regards to this one of
the things that you guys will have
noticed is that with x-men phase 1 that
was largely introducing the x-men to the
MCU phase 2 was a few stories involving
the x-men after that that helped to
expand on the x-men lineup the Fantastic
Four phase 1 was introducing the
Fantastic Four into the MCU for the most
part I would keep the Fantastic Four as
background characters I would give them
like a huge moment later on down the
line but the the Fantastic Four were
really more of a team where because of
the fact that they were kind of
relegated to the background once their
popularity dropped off and really unlike
the sixties I'm sorry in the 70s to the
to the mid 80s I would sort of keep them
there and I would give him like the huge
moment probably Hickman's run a
Fantastic Four that would just be like
their great big huge thing instead what
I would do here is that would break away
from like huge sections huge swaths of
movies that are designed to focus on
like the x-men in Fantastic Four
said I would start focusing on smaller
things they would basically be like solo
movies more or less and the first way I
would kick this off is with fatal
attractions now fatal attractions is one
of the coolest stories out there when it
comes to the x-men but this serves a
couple different purposes this allows us
to give us to have a movie with the
x-men are largely in isolation the only
exception of that is like Excalibur e71
was part of the original story for those
guys who don't know fatal attractions
was a story that ran between July and
November of 1993 and I want to say it
was like x-factor 92 x-men maybe was
x-force 25 um and then I know it was
uncanny x-men 304 x-men vol 2 25 and
Wolverine number 75 I'm not gonna swear
by that I'm pretty sure that's right
though but the fact remains in Marvel
Comics this was a story where magneto
had effectively taken up with regards to
a group that was calling themselves the
um oh my god I can't remember what they
were but they were they were led by
Fabian Cortez and I can never remember
what this group is called but the
general idea here is that Marvel Comics
had something called asteroid M which
appeared all the way back in 1964
eventually asteroid M was destroyed and
the character cable who had long since
showed up in the Marvel Universe his uh
his ship Graymalkin was basically
co-opted by magneto and turned into a
base of operations that existed out in
space now we don't have to bring in
Graymalkin we don't have to bring in
cable we can largely take the concept of
asteroid him and just roll it into the
idea of Avalon this new place that it
that magneto basically runs but the idea
here was that magneto took this this
location as Avalon you know Graymalkin
essentially petitioned to the worlds
mutant population and said if you do not
want to live under the yoke of
oppression of humanity then come live
here now this ran directly against the
entire ideology that Xavier was shooting
for which was a peaceful coexistence
between humans and mutants more so than
that where Xavier was willing to let it
slide
humanity was not humanity saw magneto as
basically marshalling forces they saw
him as a person who was just gathering
all these mutants together and then
eventually would intend to just launch
this massive attack against humanity
what didn't help was the fact that
magneto also had his base of operations
outfitted with nuclear weapons
and so the result was that humanity
maybe it was humanity that launched
nuclear weapons at him but regardless of
the circumstance Humanity struck first
and the result was that magneto
basically arrived on earth and then just
let out this blanket EMP across the face
of the planet that effectively took down
power to everything now the x-men
rallied
they went to go meet with with Magneto
and when they tried to talk him out of
it a fight ensued and then you know of
course as most everybody knows by now
wolverine went to go attack magneto
magneto got tired of it ain't just
ripped the mat a roofie adamantium out
of his body but that would make a really
really cool a really cool film that led
into like the onslaught saga which we
don't really have to go into you but
that would make an interesting scenario
because it builds on really the nature
of of magneto is kind of like this
incorrigible guy but you could even huge
the idea of magneto saying he loves
mutants like family that in a lot of
ways he views them his brothers and
sisters and children and so on and so
forth so it's not done out of malice
it's not done by a nanny know to
basically make himself some godly
deities that everybody will worship you
know instead it's him basically saying I
think this is legitimately the best
thing that we can do and that's it you
wrapped the movie up you don't continue
it on you don't build it up into
something bigger it doesn't lay the
groundwork for things later on instead
it's largely just a self-contained film
I mean of course you know you kind of
spin that off so maybe Wolverine runs
into the woods and he becomes feral
Wolverine and you realize that he's got
bone claws instead of you know having
been at an auntie all the time we know
that now just by nature of the Fox films
but we may not know that with regards to
how Wolverine is depicted in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Disney may choose to
keep that part of his history Disney may
choose to change that part of this
history so if we don't really know
exactly what they're gonna do but the
next phase that I where I'm sorry the
next film that I would do after this
would actually be the story where
Franklin Richards becomes avatar and it
would be Fantastic Four and number 245
now what we would do here and there's a
few ways that we can handle this in a
lot of ways we can basically sort of sum
up the origin of Franklin Richards in
the first 15 minutes and it's not
complicated the origin of Franklin
Richards is very very simple the idea
here was that Susan storm was pregnant
with a kid ah she was going through
troubles with the pregnancy the child
was siphoning off basically all of her
life energy and the only way for Reed
and company to find a way to counteract
that was to travel to the negative zone
now we can do that we can say that in
like Fantastic Four phase 1 when we have
the Fantastic Four going through and
exploring the universe or whatever
that's somewhere off-screen they came
across the negative zone but inside the
negative zone is a being called a
nihilist we doesn't have to be super
complicated that could be something that
they explained in like five minutes you
know and then from there they launch it
they orchestrate an attack they
basically go in they steal the cosmic
control rod from Annihilus which is
essentially a weapon that Annihilus uses
that's equal to Galactus in power but
it's in the negative zone and then from
there they bring it back and they
effectively help Susan storm give birth
you can do all that
in 20 minutes or you can explain how it
all happened you can do that super fast
and the result is that this goes into
Fantastic Four number 245 now Fantastic
Four number 245 was a story where Susan
storm returned home only to find that
all the Fantastic Four were gone they
had effectively been removed in their
entirety actually now that I think about
I think Johnny Storm lost his powers um
I think that like Ben Grimm was human or
something along those lines but
regardless it looked like somebody had
basically broken in and then like
defeated and eliminated all the
Fantastic Four and so Susan storm was
trying to make her way through the
building in its entirety and then she
basically comes across like a grown man
with blond hair who really looks like
Jesus and what you find out is that
Franklin Richards the son of Reid is a
kid who has like this vast
reality-warping power and he was a he
was a little kid sitting in front of a
TV playing with blocks and a commercial
came on and they made the statement when
are you gonna grow up and subconsciously
Franklin Richards made himself an adult
and because of the fact that he was an
adult and his powers were fully
manifested he didn't know how to use
them and so he was essentially a grown
adult in a you know with a child's mind
confused about the world around him and
didn't know how to function eventually
Reid talks him down he comes to and
that's really the end of that but it's
cool because what this does is it puts
the power of Franklin Richards on
display and it essentially says look we
don't need some huge grandiose story
where Franklin you know Mexica Locke
disses Herald like he does in Hickman's
Rahn you know he's like to marry my
Galactus you know we don't need all that
kind of craziness we'll do that later on
what we need is just a solid display of
the power of Franklin Richards and what
better way to do that than Franklin
Richards making himself an adult D
powering the Fantastic Four and then in
turn warping reality around him in a
localized space it kind of sets the
stage for the fact that if his powers
aren't controlled adequately then he'll
basically run amuck and so at the end of
this movie you essentially put in place
the idea that Reed Richards installs
mental blocks in his son's mind so the
Franklin can only use small portions of
its power so what we end up having is
this sort of teasing idea that somewhere
along the line those mental blocks will
be removed and when they are what the
hell kind of power is Franklin Richards
get a half now from there we switch back
over to the x-men again and we again
continue to focus on this idea of how
the x-men are dealing with things in
truth we kind of take this a little bit
out of chronology what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna cover God loves man
kills now God knows man kills is an
amazing story and in fact that was the
basis behind the film x-men - I think it
was
man kills is a story that focuses on a
guy named William Stryker but where Fox
turned William Stryker into a military
guy in Marvel Comics William Stryker is
a Christian evangelical he believes is
his mission from God to kill mutants now
that will be controversial when you have
a country where something like 80% or
better of people are Christians and then
you in turn say here's a here's a movie
about the x-men where the main guy is a
person who's crazy
and he believes God wants him to kill
mutants it's probably gonna piss off
Christians but it's a comic book movie
they'll be okay and so because of that
what we ended up having in this story
was a really in-depth in an incredible
tale this was essentially the idea that
William Stryker led a group called the
purifiers and as hardcore as it may seem
and as brutal as it may seem the
purifiers the opening scene of the movie
was a purifiers killing a couple of kids
and the idea was you don't deserve to
live you're an abomination that
immediately set in stone the idea that
the purifiers are incorrigible the
purifiers cannot be fixed they believe
with their heart and soul that William
Stryker will lead them to paradise if
they eliminate all these different
mutants it brings in at the very nature
what it means to be part of a cult what
it means to be a believer and so because
that William Stryker couldn't
necessarily be defeated through
conventional means the defeat of William
Stryker came at the hands of a debate
between Cyclops and William over whether
or not mutants were considered to be an
abomination at the hands of God and
because what what Cyclops ended up doing
here is basically arguing look if God
made man and mutants are simply just the
next step in human evolution then if God
is all-knowing God had to know this was
gonna be the case now honestly
Cyclops argued it more from like an
evolutionary standpoint but the fact
remains it boiled down to a debate in
William Stryker effectively having been
defeated and embarrassed on national
television pulled a gun on Cyclops and
that was the end of him he was basically
arrested people saw him for the crazy
person that he was but it was
effectively the x-men dealing with this
idea that there are beings out there who
for whatever reason are never going to
like them they're never gonna tolerate
them they're never gonna understand them
and they're gonna have no desire to and
you can't win all your problems by just
shooting somebody with optic blasts and
blowing them in half that was the beauty
of God loves man kills I would grab that
and I would throw it in there now
following that I would move away from
the entirety of like the American
superhero community and I travel to
England and I would give us the origin
of Captain Britain now Captain Britain
is not the most intriguing character out
there but what it would do with bringing
his character in Israel to expand the
Marvel Cinematic Universe it would grow
it in a way that doesn't necessarily
have to do with cosmic Hughes and
Infinity stones instead ryan braddock is
basically a guy who drew a weird series
of circumstances was essentially
introduced to two potential weapons one
was the amulet of right and the other
one was the sword of might I think it
was and he chose the amulet which
basically grants him like a shield and
you know flight and superhuman strength
and so on and so forth but the idea of
Captain Britain can invoke a huge person
it's like it's a huge introduction to
the MCU that wasn't there before Captain
Britain is one part of a multiversal
group called a Captain Britain Corps
every universe has his own captain
britain on some of these captain Britons
are familiar characters that we know
Reed Richards or like Cyclops or
Professor X but sometimes you know for
the most part they're characters that we
don't know but what captain Brit would
also do is it was expand on the
multiverse where dr. strange said hey
there's like there's a bunch of
universes out there there's an infinite
number of universes and god only knows
what's inside of them the Captain
Britain Court would expand on that and
it would essentially say not only is
there a multiversal peacekeeping force
it's designed to ensure that each of
their earths each of their universes are
safe what you also have is the
omniversal development court that is
basically this group that monitors the
multiverse and essentially says okay
look so like every universe should have
an x-men every universe should have the
Fantastic Four every universe should
have an Avengers they should have
superpower beings if they don't then
we'll jumpstart their evolution to make
sure that happens and so that's the
purpose the omniversal development court
first it helps to expand on that it
helps to expand on the very nature of
what the multiverse is and the different
groups that function inside of it now
how we bring that in is really up to
anybody's guess you can be written in
any number of ways we don't have to
necessarily go into like the origin of
saturnine or anything like that we can
just kind of grab these characters that
exist out there and then just throw them
into the movie and say here's how the
multiverse functions and here's a guy
that anchors us to it so if we can kind
of look forward to the idea that
whenever is we see Captain Britain maybe
we'll get to experience the multiverse
or something along those lines but
following that I would walk away I would
come back not necessarily from you know
from Britain itself or focus on any one
particular country instead I would focus
on earth and I would do this by focusing
on the Eternals now the Eternals are a
really really really cool group that
exists in Marvel Comics it is a group
that they have a really really small fan
base but the small fan base is really
really passionate so the way this works
in Marvel Comics is you have
all manner of super-powered beings you
have mutants who have Avengers but the
whole idea with the Eternals is that
somewhere along the line in Earth's
history the celestial beings showed up
on earth just like they showed up on
countless planets across the universe
and they were effectively performing
experiments and the whole idea here was
that they showed up on earth and they
said okay so here's like really
primitive men when they're basically
Neanderthals and we're going to
experiment on them for one group of
these people their genes are gonna be
modified and they're gonna go forward
living their lives the way they always
did but somewhere along the line these
genes are gonna activate and when they
do mutants are gonna start popping up on
the scene either that or their genes are
gonna be modified so that if they're
exposed to like gamma rays they become
something like The Incredible Hulk
instead of just being covered in
blisters and sores and die of radiation
sickness but the other two groups were
the Eternals and they were the deviants
the Eternals were basically angelic in
terms of how they appeared they were
almost heavenly and they were able to
fly and different things like that
the deviants lived underground and we
can explore that we can really kind of
tie that in and say that in the early
days of humanity with cave drawings that
drew alien visitors and different things
like that those are the Celestials when
people start talking about oh man there
were angels that came down from heaven
and helped us to win that battle
those were Eternals and they were just
fighting on the side of humanity you can
tie that into the idea that the concept
of religion is just a fact that at one
point in time people couldn't understand
the world around them so they just use
whatever means they could to understand
it and that's where those religious
contexts come from you could grab those
things and throw it in there and it
works because then from there you can
bookend in to fan oohs you can say okay
so they were lucky turtles that lived on
earth but not all of them wanted to stay
here and so some of the Eternals left
earth and they took up residence on
Titan and you ended up having a civil
war among those Eternals the good guys
ultimately won and then somewhere along
the line
Thanos was born and so you can basically
say if you trace it back long enough
Thanos was born on Titan he's born to
the Eternals of Titan the Eternals of
Titan came from Earth and they came from
Earth because at one point they were
human ie Santos is human he didn't grab
those things and bring them together you
can string those thoughts together and
create more of an intertwine in cohesive
Marvel Cinematic Universe that of course
assumes v anos is even alive by the time
infinity war ends which I really hope he
is but at that point I would move away
and I would get to the final film of
this face and again this hits back at
the x-men and this is one of the more
significant moments with regards to the
x-men history what I would do is I would
cover ia's for extinction now what does
does is it allows Marvel to essentially
introduce the x-men and to simply say
okay so Xavier hid the x-men from the
minds of everybody on earth and where
nobody knew that they existed now that
people are aware there's millions of ax
men that live out there there's so many
x-men is absolutely insane he is for
extinction would be a stand-in for house
of M what we would do is we would say
sometime after the events of fatal
attractions magneto had taken over the
island of Genosha and when he did he
basically told everybody if you want to
live away from humanity come live here
now the eyelid Genosha has a pretty
complicated history and Marvel Comics in
truth Genosha as it was originally
debuted in 1988 was basically just a
place that was largely uninhabited it's
an island off the coast of Africa near
Madagascar but what you can say is while
it eventually became the Republic of
Genosha and it was ruled by a political
party you could say okay what everybody
became aware of mutants existence that
one of the biggest things is the
government responded with project
wide-awake and they had to control the
mutant threat in the United States but
let's expand beyond that what if the
pursuit of the mutant race for various
uses is not limited to government
intervention and finding a way to
control them but what if it expands to
like capitalist intervention what if
people sit down what if a government
sits down and says look I mean the US
can capture mutants all they wants you
out of fear and they can just throw them
in cells but like why not put him to
work why not make them into a work force
and that's what happened in Genosha and
Marvel Comics Genosha was a slave Island
it was an island where mutants were
kidnapped and taken collars were slapped
around there next to their powers could
be could only be used under certain
circumstances and they were put to work
and the whole success of Genosha the
massive amount of wealth they generated
was all based on slave labor and
humanity for the most part knew about it
but it has turned a blind eye to it
because at the end of the day if mutants
were being used for slaves on Genosha
they weren't attacking cities and nobody
really had to worry about him so at the
end of the day it benefited humanity you
can grab that whole capitalist element
and roll it in and when the person is
watching that movie they're just kind of
like man that's ridiculous but I mean
that's entirely possible
the relatability is what would make that
significant but that's the kind of you
know idea that you bring in with the
nature of Genosha itself the es for
extinction element comes in when you
basically hit on this idea that there is
some sort of hidden ham there's some
sort of being out there a person named
Cassandra Nova she's a mystery nobody
really knows anything about her we don't
know what her origin is but what we do
know is that she's managed to get her
hands on
wild sentinels and you can tie that in
to project wide-awake you can say well
where the federal government
reinitiated a cinema program they're the
signals as we saw them in that x-men
phase that was just one variation of
them the government was experimenting
with a wide array of different kinds of
sentinels and some of those projects
were abandoned and gifs and Renova came
across one of them and had an engineer
basically the grandson I think of all of
our Trask reawaken these sentinels and
then she sent them to Genosha and had
them Massacre 16 million mutants the
entire Genosha population gets totally
obliterated during ia's forge station
it's insane
that's where you you know we're like
Emma Frost for example I gained her
secondary mutation of turning into a
diamond form it was her as a teacher on
on Genosha and when all these signals
showed up they just obliterated
everything they found they took no
prisoners all those mutants were
completely and totally destroyed but you
basically leave it on this idea that
it's like wow you know humanity really
just doesn't care about mutants you
basically put it in a place where things
become exceedingly dark and what you do
is you use that as a catalyst to
basically have the x-men begin looking
around and saying if this is how
humanity wants it to be then this is the
way it can be
and suddenly x-men start sort of turning
against humanity and it sets the ground
level it sets the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a position to where you can
start moving in the direction of events
like Avengers vs. x-men if you could
start bringing all that into the
equation where the x-men see Humanity as
a credible threat they see Humanity no
longer as a group that they can work
with but instead as a group that should
probably be eliminated or at the very
least should be made to understand their
place in the bigger picture with regards
to how weak they are in comparison to
the various mutants that are out there
but with that being said guys just my
idea for this face let me know what you
guys think if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys have
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all neither peace
[Music]